hello and so I'm gonna be talking you
through how the BBC will give you
instruction to the Semantic Web first
and give you the like a bit of context
the BBC and how they've used it in the
past and how we're using it now and so
I'll just go straight into it oh no yep
so BBC started in 1922 with radio went
on to broadcast TV in 1936 then so you
get the BBC micro in 1982 anyone here
ever used a BBC micro or would have one
well I need that me some of you I don't
really know what they are coz I'm
basically 12 they're going on throughout
this of innovations we've made it brings
us to you today so why have I told you
that because it's quite significant and
kind of explains the problem we're
having today in that the legacy of our
innovation has allowed to keep us ahead
of the game but it's also me we've got a
lot of legacy systems in play and
they're all kind of existing in their
own separate data silos so bringing in
the concept of a data silo
it's a metaphor for some data on a
system which is difficult to access from
another system or from other parts of
the organization and they conform for
various reasons cultural or
technological I think the BBC is both
just the way it's formed and the you
know the size of the organisation and
that kind of sets the problem it sets
the context for the problem that we're
dealing with we want to bring all this
data together to get sort of actual
insight from it all but that's not a
knee problem plenty of other companies
face our problem what makes us unique is
that way of public service we're a
public service broadcaster this comes
with the caveat that we're funded by you
hopefully your lawyer license players
you know and we we exist to serve the
audience and Wealth's remaining
impartial and non-commercial
and that kind of sets up an into
interesting problems base for us because
we have we have to consider ethics we
have to consider what's right for the
audience so we raise our sort of
questions while we work on this stuff
like do we just serve audiences content
which they know and love and they can
just binge on it all day
I do we actually challenge their views
do we take them out of their kind of
chamber of things at the risk of
potentially making them value the BBC
less it's an interesting question to
pose how much data do we collect more
audience was comfortable with I mean I
imagine most people would say no nazo
but then how are we supposed to save
them if we don't know so there's a
balance and we have to do it how to
delicately and ethically enough to again
provide for the audience and then do we
open all algorithms up to public
scrutiny there's not a lot of companies
really go down and open-source our
algorithms and things and we'd like to
do that but then this risk of people
game flying the algorithms and things of
this news recommendation or something
like that so with all these questions as
context it's the kind of thing we're
thinking about while developing these
new systems and so just briefly
introduce you to myself I'm 23 data
engineer at VC I started my interest in
data science and data engineering might
the idea project we are told to upload
the human brain theoretical project
turned out it's impossible unless you
have 50 billion pounds and know a lot of
smart people and I was coming off this
dip into a 3 beta sites then into my
fourth year project which was detecting
dangerous mosquitoes was in the
smartphone audio sensors and turn out to
be pretty effective is really amazing
stuff and really got me hooked and where
I went straight out the Uni into a
start-up for a few months
called Q and we're working on a pair of
smart glasses to help visually impaired
people pick up nonverbal communications
by translating visual stuff into sounds
that was excellent and now I found
myself here talking to you lot
as a data engineer so our team data lab
we were fairly new year old we've been
tasked to solve this problem of these
data silos connect the BBC together we
exist within connected data within
Technology Strategy in architecture
within design engineering within the BBC
and it's okay crack on with the Semantic
Web start with the context before the
internet maybe some of the year round I
certainly wasn't in in academia
especially there's papers for
referencing other papers and to go from
one paper to another you actually had to
get a physical copy of that yet to do
sometimes done by posts it was generally
a difficult process so this bloke came
along who knows who he is
anyone just shut up yes I'm glad I would
have been very upset no one knew he came
along and proposed HTML HTTP and ER ELLs
as a kind of system to abstract this
process away and make it easy to connect
documents together he proposed the
actual idea of the Semantic Web in the
late nineties published it in 2002 in
the Scientific American and the face
will show the sort of alien vision of
the website where 1.0 this was known as
the read phase of the web so web sites
are mostly static documents but you
could click from one website to another
without knowing anything about how they
were all connected abstracted the way
this process and he's there in the
middle of it all just doing it all and
then oh and oh yeah I forgot to break
that up with us well it looked like
useful as you can see and I wish we
could go back to that and that was
pulled from the Wayback Machine the BBC
website in 1996
and then we get to web 2.0 the kind of
right phase of the web and this is kind
of where we're at now we're active
participation sharing collaboration from
users is encouraged but kind of funneled
into different silos so Facebook
LinkedIn Twitter all these other ones
they all collect users data and keep it
to themselves and that's where the value
proposition comes from holding this data
and this doesn't well again going on to
the web 3.0 the idea of it the Semantic
Web the execute was that we'd share all
our data though these application silos
wouldn't exist everyone would just have
this common data to use but that's not a
realistic kind of thing to assume it's
not likely to happen this is where the
value comes from and not going to
suddenly give away all their data for
that reason there's very mixed opinions
surrounding the Semantic Web and I
personally say that the original vision
of the Semantic Web probably not
happened there won't be this open spread
Internet everything's accessible all the
day successful but it turns out the
technologies behind it are very useful
for the problem that we're trying to
solve linking data across silos because
you can link data of different types and
really emphasize the relationships in
this data so linked data is what Tim
berners-lee called the Semantic Web done
right it's kind of like an
implementation of it it has the P key
concepts around it
everything has a URI this is a uniform
resource identifier you might catch me
saying other things but it's definitely
that one and everything has a URI branks
PRI PI data as a URI and I know that
man's beard they're probably as a URI if
you're modeling that and they're all
distinct and they must be ideally direct
municipal
so HTTP URLs and you follow one and you
get more information on that and you can
traverse the whole system with your eyes
you must define the relationship you
can't just throw any load of objects and
expect them to link up and talk to each
other and oh well that's some machine
learning with us kind of later evolution
of this and ideally use a standard
format so your data can be shared you
can push publics buckle endpoints and
sorry push the public end points where
you can query your data and public and
other companies can access it so I'll
take you through the technology stack of
these Semantic Web
starting with RDF and so RDF is a data
model for representing resources and
relationships between those resources
it's flexible and scheme lists so it
relies as a descriptive scheme rather
than a prescriptive schema so as opposed
to relational databases they have the
prescriptive schema which if you trying
out data which doesn't fit with the
schema it's not going to be happy with
it's not going to work quite resistant
to change whereas if you are data T and
this descriptive schema system which
fits the schema fine if it doesn't fit
then you can still do it and it can
still link in and it adds information
it's not necessary it's quite simple way
of representing knowledge but it's so
powerful and the fact that it's machine
readable makes it so much more valuable
you can have and machines understand all
the facts and statements are asserting
and make new inferences from those facts
which I'll talk about later and so the
form of RDF is subject predicate and
object so the subject could be something
like sky the predicate could be color
and the color object could be blue it's
another example me I work at BBC the BBC
produces Doctor Who and doctor who has a
rating of excellent and these are all
assertions of facts remember
and there's many different sea
realizations of this RDF model these are
just ways of representing it already act
as a model and not to be confused with
total wind quads and ripples etc they're
just different ways of explaining the
same problem so we'll go into ontology
x' now which form quite a fundamental
part of the Semantic Web ontology is
allow us to represent knowledge as a
series of concepts linked together yep
it's a way of marking knowledge and it
could be very the rules and constraints
and it can be very easily extended so if
you've got a data set of a triple store
with loads of data and then you want to
add more of a different form you can
extend it extend the ontology just keep
it growing using that you can affair new
knowledge which I'll talk about on the
next slide and as an example of some
existing ontology we have our DFS rdf
schema which is the kind of most basic
you can start inferring well you start
saying classes and properties and things
about these rdf statements you're making
is kind of the most basic one than
extending from that we've got the web
ontology language which you can start
making and it's a lot more complex than
our DFS and you can build upon that and
use that for references which is quite
powerful but you got to be careful with
it talk about later and then we have
this kind of are there existing ontology
which is domain-specific knowledge so
the simple knowledge organization system
used to link organization systems
together or the friend of a friend both
and where it talks about human
relationships and social networks
contacts information things like that so
there's lots of domain-specific
knowledge and then as an example a very
basic example of an ontology say I was
linking to BBC systems together one was
TV system one was radio and they're
described as video and audio and their
services
in this system I'm bringing them into
you I can say they're both a subclass of
media and then three queries and things
I can say oh and all the media items and
they'll give me anything which is a
subclass of media and that's very basic
example but it's just shows you kind of
how these relationships are defined we
can take that one step further I start
to use invariance so if we say Gerald is
a cat and then we can say this cat is a
subclass of the animal if we run an owl
reasoning engine over this we can
actually fit the information from it so
we can create this triple without
actually having it in saying Gerald is
an animal and and you can do much more
advanced things than the height so it's
married again very basic examples to
illustrate a quick and next we have
Sparkle which is the query language and
I thought it'd be much better to
illustrate it through a demo rather than
just talking to the syntax so I'll set
out the context of it will be using
dbpedia which is a sort of public facing
sparkle endpoint of lots of collected
media from different Wikimedia projects
and says got a load of information about
subjects basically and we'll be
accessing it using RDF Lib which is a
Python library the most common one to
access and manipulate rdf and sparkle
wrapper which wraps around the public
endpoint and sort of abstracts it your
Python code so let's pose this question
I'm going to read Alice's difficult to
remember let's find the genres of any
music produced by a band with a member
born the year but Elon Musk was born
where any of the members were also born
in the UK okay and a different screen
actually oh it's there okay come see ya
okay can you all see that okay yeah my
glasses so we start by creating a object
to interact with the sparkle endpoint so
do you and I'm gonna be using pythons or
handy shortcuts a lot I just put these
up here handily for me this is the
dbpedia endpoint the anyone can access
you can play along at home if you want
pop in here just import that and then we
have a store object so let's build a
query I'll start with the most basic
query where we basically get all the
triples from the database so we start
with select and probably all familiar
with select subject predicate and
objects which is the things I was
referencing before and then we need a
little where in there and anything
inside of where is basically to put it
simply pattern matching so if I say the
pattern is then that's basically saying
they've got three variables here without
any constraints match all the triples
and then we'll execute that query by
just going store query and pop our query
in here
yes and I just made a little handy
function here to print all the results
so let's run that
oh no you can never trust a live demo
can you why do you have one I made
earlier but would it be nice to show you
this any any that should take oh oh I
know exactly why because no it was a lie
okay well go to what I made earlier and
just talk you to you out it's a shame
can I change project from here I'm gonna
have to exit demo mode sorry about this
folks I called it Plan B okay so I'll
just talk you through this basically
same
yeah slightly different syntax here but
that yeah so we've got the sparkle store
here oh that's what I did I import the
module assorted
too late to get back now I'm invested in
this okay so we've opened our store with
the endpoint here and then we've created
a namespace manager object which is part
of our DF flip and that needs an RDF for
the graph object to operate on so we
just pop our store like sparkle wrapper
store into that it the graph takes that
and treats it as a sort of native
inbuilt graph objects and then the
namespace manager is a way of managing
these ontology so that you want to use
the query so I added DB r and d Bo so
that describes the dbpedia resources
which are objects things like Elon Musk
or AB and anything like that
and DB are sorry DB o which is the
ontology so the things that describe the
relationship between these objects and
their faith which is friend of a friend
I would have used that earlier in the
demo so I'll take you through here we've
just found the namespaces using the name
stage manager so now if I send the query
these abbreviations here will expand to
these URLs by the time it hits the end
point and so what we've done here is
we've selected the genre from all the
way down here said distinct because we
don't want a load of repeated genres
because that was our final goal to get
the genre which and and we said find the
birth year of Elon Musk and call it this
variable here Elon Musk Beth you we then
sort of thought that will match any
triples which match that and will only
be one because he only has one birthday
unless and so separately we find any
band so this this pattern here we'll
just find everything which is tagged as
a band in dbpedia we then take that
using this shortcut here we're still
operating on this band variable and we
say we want band members associated with
this band and then this slash here will
traverse to the next link and we say we
want the birth years of those band
members and we have this variable here
on birth year which we've already kind
of defined so or match all the triples
with the bounty of band members the same
bit year as Elon Musk much in a similar
way we'll do the band members again and
get the birth place which will be a town
and then we have to get the country of
that town so we've traversed two links
there and we could say in the united
kingdom and of this band that we've now
narrowed down to these two kind of
criteria find the genre and so let's run
that and it will run yep and we've got
warm result and thought it is very
boring it's a cover band probably the
most disappointing answer but there you
go we've managed to do quite a complex
query live and yeah close the
presentation now still way and so you've
kind of found some triples which match
this graph one trip or in fact and so
that was kind of a link data stack we've
got the RDF as the data model ontology
is too
linked these entities together had the
information and we have Sparkle to query
this data that we have and so what is it
like pull together you get potential if
you do it right you can get a knowledge
graph and this basically sits on top of
all of your data silos abstracted away
and makes your data and actionable asset
you can see you can get insights like
the silos weren't even there and so I'll
just go on to show you what's available
at the moment there's a ton of different
graph database solutions all quite
different and so some of them have
particular implementations of the stack
some can import and export it but they
work with something else and some are
kind of a different model like a
property graph model where you can
describe the relationships I'll talk
about that a bit so there is limitations
with the linked data stack it's a high
learning curve because this this idea
was born of academia or 20 years ago and
this main development has been through
academia and I found when I was
researching this stuff trying to learn
it if I went beyond the basic stuff and
stop dealing how to do X Y is out there
sparkle it's just academic papers and
the occasional poor sod he's trying to
ask on Stack Exchange and getting no
answers is because of this kind of
difficult uptake there's also a limited
availability of tools and if no one's
using it no one really wants to develop
for it and but there is there is hope
there's starting to be something be an
uptake from the big big provider so
eight AWS releasing net units and
preview at the moment this is a
massively distributed graph database
based on some of these technologies but
also you can use some others so it's
quite their style quite interesting and
and another trouble with this the
documentation it's all very correct and
accurate and perfect if you know
anything about it and how to use it but
if you're learning it it's it just takes
time and people don't
wants to do that people are lazy so then
next limitation is binary statements ODF
can you can say anything in a triple but
you can't say anything about that triple
if you want to add provenance
information such as if I was tagging a
piece of media with a tag how confident
am I about that time you have to then
add to reify the data add another are
they three or four triples to represent
that one thing it's a bit messy and the
more you do that the sort further away
you get from your sort cool data model
but it is possible it just requires a
bit more thinking about but because of
that if you've got pretty like complex
data set which requires lots of
provenance information then you get a
proliferation of triples you can end up
so compared to a property graph which
you can label the connections you can
end up with the database 10 times bigger
then we have the open world assumption
so I was talking about inference before
and the our reasoning engines are used
to do that but it uses a open world
assumption so if I say Gerald is a cat
and cats eat food but I then add a
triple saying derald is food
owl would not say no this is wrong
gerald can't be food he's a cat I would
say cat is food and eat is is like it it
would try and make it something
consistent even if it didn't make sense
in your model so you've got to be
careful for that there is tools at the
moment such as star dog which does have
an integrity verification but it's just
something you gotta be aware of when
you're working with lots of our
reasoning and then we have the question
of visit scaleable that's kind of the
most common thing asked about audio in
the Semantic Web stack and usually when
dealing with scalability and there's
observational databases you take your
data and split it up put it on different
systems and scale out horizontally and
usually the data cluster on these
systems is related and this a bit more
difficult with RDF because the unit of
data is much smaller and these
relationships can become a lot more
complex and so the difficulty to
partition increases it becomes like
graph partitioning problem which is
difficult it's not impossible it's just
a lot more challenging and this less
established as its scale up the platform
so there's still some work to be done
but seeing that there is hybrid
solutions which do exist such as Janus
graph is built on Google BigTable like
databases so Cassandra things like that
and you can have that as your data
storage and then have the layer of the
earth than other semantic technologies
on top of that and so there's some
limitations there to be aware of and you
know it's it's not something you can
just choose and it'll solve all your
problems
it's it fits in certain contexts so to
give it a context with other data
storage paradigms yeah the key value so
very basic often used for caches just
keys and values the values are sort of
opaque blobs in regards to the query
engine then we have the next level up
that's the documents tool similar to key
value store but the value is now
indexable you can query engine use it to
optimize the queries but it's not really
built for relation relationships you
can't have some relationships but it's
not designed for that but they're both
blazingly fast and simple let me have
wide column databases which is what
Janus graph is based off massive amounts
of data it's hugely scalable and very
denormalized source of duplicated data
but I can just scale it out like that
and then you're probably familiar with
SQL most of you and it's a very mature
technology got a large choice of tool
that's been around for ages and but if
you start trying to shove new types of
data into it it'll struggle with
especially you've got a huge established
system to change a column can be a
million dollar problem you know all of
this entirely depends on your context
and choosing the right storage solutions
and then bring in the graph databases I
briefly mentioned earlier property
graphs and so with property graph so you
can label the relationships so if I'm
saying how confident I am about target
and just pop out on the
the property itself is an object which
you can attach things to with these
systems there's not really a standard
for them an open standard so each
solution tends to work with a different
language some of them have sort of
things bolted on where you can use
Sparkle and import and export audio but
it gets kind of messy and it wouldn't be
the same as if you can designed it for
four it's already a based system
although saying that if it if you do
what my kind of thing want to close it
off then it's excellent fast
transactional support and you've got
strong path analysis then we have RDF
databases and there's a standard data
model this is also defined in w3c
standards Sparkle RDF and ontology these
are all defined they're open standards
and there's a lot of platforms built on
this because of this your data is highly
portable there's no vendor lock-in
you could eat bees in three different
systems simultaneously although that
would defeat the point of trying to
unify everything but if you wanted to
and you can use the sort of powerful
inference tools of owl and things I was
discussing before and so there's you got
to choose a thing appropriate to the
problem and we at the BBC have tend to
stick with RDF because we're about
opening up we're about sharing our data
where we can providing services for the
audience so I'll just briefly take you
through the link to data and how they
use it in the busey so there's the
linked data platform it was big in
around 2012 some of you may have heard
of it they aggregated content that
matters to the BBC and its audiences so
things outside of the BBC and then some
things within BC they put it into a
knowledge graph and pockets all together
they used it to power the World Cup 2010
in the Linux 2012 so it's kind of
perfect for that solution where you have
these entities of athletes teams
countries events all linking together
with different kind of medals
and about people process playing in the
game different countries etc is quite
powerful when you can start doing this
complicated queries you can really get
quick insights without any extra costs
of hurting it and someone to delve
through it and today I believe it's
still in use to save the topics for the
BBC News app and serve some BBC sports
website content and using some
journalistic tools where the journalist
is writing an article people will have
our tag generating API and it'll
generate tags on the fly and then put
these into the links data platform now
BC things all connections not really
sure what it's called anymore and then
recommend articles as they're writing so
they can see what's already existing on
the BBC and they can get a real context
of what's what they're writing about and
then we have the research and education
space and their idea was to as a
four-year project me collaborated with
lots of academic students curators to
aggregate content from libraries museums
galleries broadcasters put it into one
space so so students and teachers
academic security so they can all use
this to gain further insight and sort of
base their research on this and then we
have how our team using at the moment so
we have been given this problem of data
silos and we're working on a Content
graph to solve it that's quite exciting
it's quite difficult
I joined six months ago and I've learned
a huge amount I actually was exposed to
these technology six months ago so I've
been learning and working with them and
come to understand a lot of their
shortcomings but a lot of the power and
we really think we can write something
amazing with this and possibly even a
hybrid solution it doesn't all have to
depend on this graph so this will power
recommendations for a new up we're
releasing there those are a team working
alongside us and
on the other side of it provide a
platform for the rest of DBC to use and
so we'll be exposing our knowledge to
the rest of the organization and
exposing out so the audiences can make
use of it and we're hiring so if any of
you are interested in working on a
problem like this get in touch come talk
to me after whatever you want we've got
four roles the data scientists that lead
eight data engineer architects executive
project manager and shoot us an email
talk to me whatever you want if you're
interested and that's it if you have any
questions
hi thanks for the talk I kind of get the
query side of things but I don't get the
index inside of things because with the
silos they're not going to be in any
kind of typical state that you're going
to want to go and index from so how does
that type work so in turn I think you're
talking about the ingest process of how
you get the data from so ideally well
you'd have to if you had a system which
is constantly bringing in data you'd
have to first do an initial ingest of
that data and convert it into RDF so
that requires some kind of modeling and
some process and then you take that in
and then you can set up a script to
monitor that and bring in change
notifications and things thank you thank
you for the talk you mentioned that
you're building the content ontology how
does it happen with the new programs as
they come out will it be special people
employed to just populate it's in your
database sorry like when a new program
comes out yeah somebody has to input it
into this new database that you're
building so when a new program comes out
the BBC it's put into the Pips database
that stores all the program metadata and
then we will set up after doing our
initial ingest so I was talking about
this gentleman we will and subscribe to
change notifications from an Amazon has
an S topic and there's no manual steps
they're just you can just ingest it
right well yeah I'll have to get their
accommodation scripts a model in audio
but that's just Amara squishing it up
into a different table that's great yeah
just there's a lot of effort it goes
into maintaining normally yes so we're
building it fast connecting to pips and
building like quite generic systems so
we'll start with ingesting this video
and clips metadata then we'll extend it
to other systems and because
RDF and ontology is extendable it
actually presents itself for this kind
of situation
thank you do we have any yes we do have
more questions sadena of any other
commercial like like Google knowledge
graph or even I am DB using RDF you know
it's not it's still quite academic late
you can't don't see any you know why do
you think you know it didn't take off so
why do you think it's different now I
think it's different now because big
companies yes so you know if you look at
the most of the like IMDB or Google
knowledge graph you know they don't
expose RDF for interface they won't they
don't right yes apparently only the only
rdfa or spark ql interfaces are for
academic projects or open source yeah so
that's was was kind of saying about the
kind of vision the original vision of
the Semantic Web didn't really work
because no one wants to open up their
endpoints like that but I think it does
the technologies are still valid for
doing it within an organization so you
don't necessarily have to open it up but
ideally you would so it's I know things
might shift but the way you know people
value data things might change and then
how do you envisage ontologies will be
synchronized across organizations so you
know you had this band thing right so
everyone who has a bands database likes
for different things wouldn't need the
same same schemas for things so without
an odd yet he can create your own
ontology so if I if I Spotify calls it a
band and Apple music calls it a miracle
group you can just in your sort of
connecting ontology if you're ingesting
it say a group musical group is the same
as band and immediately that will treat
them as the same thing okay thank you so
we probably have a time for one more
quick question any more questions okay
that's it oh yeah thanks just following
on that one I don't know if you have for
example
come across a scheme Authority which is
you know the Google version of RTFM and
that's kind of taking over just because
well every website wants to be captured
by Google so I've got more more take on
but I don't know I think think yeah RDF
is better but have you consider for
example is key mythology and I so I did
I don't know each one but I think
impossible with this whole link data
stack or are they trying to build it as
a separate system which yeah is
essentially the the way you know if
you're a web developer developing your
website and what we cover and you know
pass all these well the idea the
Semantic Web by Google to be part of
their knowledge graph then they would
recommend just follow the schema Dority
standard that kind of there are ways to
transfer and yeah translating to RDF RDF
lights because there are several version
of RDF but yeah that seems to be the one
that is taking more just because of the
the need of people to be you know found
by search by Google so that will
probably take off and raise awareness of
it but they'll still definitely be a
needs to run your own sort of in-house
knowledge graphs and things distributed
on AWS or something so I think they'll
probably develop side by side with
positive effects I imagine CEO fantastic
talk let's thank Theo